so let me ask you about this point that
your chairman is made he wants he's
prepared to sign a non spying agreement
isn't that pretty terrible that you need
to make a promise to a country when
you're operating in it if if it helps we
will sign in a non spying agreement with
the UK government there are mechanisms
already in place within the UK in fact
according to NCS see is the most
rigorous activity with with Huawei
globally but if it requires us to sign a
non spying agreement it would be very
happy to do that that's a pretty pass
though isn't it to have to make a
commitment like that in order to do
business in the country
we're in unusual times and you know the
press is full of articles from elsewhere
from the United States saying that we
know Huawei is is not a company that
they want to do business with so we
recognize we need to go the extra mile
to reassure the UK and we're willing to
do that so why is it do you think that
countries like the United States Japan
Australia New Zealand won't let you into
their 5g networks so we we think they've
called it wrong in some respects the
United States is under invested in in 5g
if you contrast that to the UK who put
5g as central to the industrial strategy
off commas release spectrum the carriers
are doing trials here in the UK we've
taken a different approach in this
country and that's I think good for the
country well one of those carriers
Vodafone has said that they're not
prepared to have you in core parts of
their network do you think they've been
told to say that by the government or is
it just that they don't trust you
themselves so so the the difference
between core and the radio access
network the antenna is is is a division
that many companies use many companies
in the world only have the same supplier
for the core and and I ran and I was in
BT for many years and diverse having a
diverse supply network is something that
is very very normal so we're comfortable
with that that some of the new networks
that were already being built we've
already shipped over a hundred thousand
base stations and signed 20 contracts
globally they are using Huawei in the
core and also in the radio access
wireless network
what about this executive order that
Donald Trump is about to sign which will
bar any company from doing business with
you is I gonna have a meaningful event
on the company's finances I don't know
the detail of that I've seen the reports
we don't do a lot of business in the
United States so I can't really comment
in terms of what impact that would have
on our business but you know we operate
in 170 countries worldwide
we carry traffic for two or three
billion of the world's population you
know the u.s. is part of that global
economy but unfortunately for us they're
not right for us right now and what sort
of assurances have the UK government
asked you for well we've had a mechanism
in place for the UK for many years now
we've been here for 18 years and in the
last eight years we've had something
called the oversight board which manages
a facility that was set up by NCSC for
us to reassure the UK that our code is
safe and they've reported and said that
there's been no interference from the
Chinese government without with our code
they obviously don't think your code is
safe they did they for sure yeah but
what about when do you expect everyone
here back from the government one way or
the other all this so the government is
doing a review led by DCMS the digital
media sport department and we expect
that report which is not about Huawei
it's about the whole industry and the
whole supply chain enabling the UK
carriers to prepare for the expansion of
5g we expect that report to come out
sometime in the spring well let's turn
to your report this 1.7 billion pound UK
GDP contribution you say I mean your
wages been in your operating profits are
only 287 million pounds or how do you
arrive at this bigger number so I could
independent consulting firm called
Oxford Economics have completed the
report which is the second report and we
felt it was appropriate to to publish
that report which gives us a status of
where we are on the UK after investing
in the UK for the last 18 years and the
report says that we have a
contribution to GDP of 1.7 billion and
in 2018 we acquired equipment from UK
suppliers valued at 900 million pounds
and we create employment for 26,000
people if you add up our direct indirect
and associated contribution to the UK
but isn't there going to be an element
of double counting here given that a lot
of that equipment will end up in the
hands of companies like BT and Vodafone
shouldn't that be their GDP contribution
rather than yours well the way it works
ian is it and this is the model that
Oxford Economics apply and it's a pretty
standard model it D tubes all of the
double counting and it says this is what
wow it contributes to the UK the 1.7
billion we've also made a commitment of
investing 3 billion over the next five
years in UK equipment so you know we're
a significant player we hope we'll be
here for some time